once he held the gun to my throat pushed
it into my throat
okay that take a
turn guys do you ever feel like money is
just flying out of your account oh I do
and you have no idea where it's going
well I know it's all those
subscriptions so guess what we used we
used rocket money to help us find out
what subscriptions we're actually
spending money on it was eye openening
and we had to cancel the ones we don't
want anymore stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions by going to
Rocket money.com DPT that's rocket
money.com DPT rocket
money.com
DPT hey toes welcome to another episode
of dumb people population you population
Patel Patel how are you Budd good how
are you guys so to have you on the show
man thanks for having me man I love that
we've hung at uh moon tower before we've
gotten a chance again whenever like our
favorite New York people make their way
out here yeah that's the underrated
thing about the moon Comedy Festival
they bring a lot of great New York
Comics lot of New York com it's AES it's
a cool reunion for us yeah for sure love
good and I love you're on tour we'll
talk about that coming up but here's the
deal you you were just telling us off
air of a story of behavior in Fresno and
I mean you can just guess what it is
people just it was insanity and it's
crazy age 6'4 Indian man collapsed drunk
at your show drunk I mean that's not
unusual what's unusual is that he gets
up and then Falls over and then you
announce are there any doctors in the
house and of course it's an Indian show
yes everyone gets up lot of everyone
gets up like okay anybody let's now make
it more specific all veterinarians sit
down and all people who are
pediatricians surgeons you were not
needed who works on the heart and like
TW
but but it is amazing because I believe
that that behavior and I don't know if
you agree with this is like becoming
more prevalent in society people are
just getting Dumber I don't know if you
feel that way alcohol consumption went
through the roof from pandemic on and
just and heighten the fact that people
are sad and alone and right Fresno is
probably uh a doubling down on that you
could tell you could you can you can
tell how isolated and sad a town is by
how drunk they are on a Thursday or
Friday
and it's like all people are trapped it
felt like like we got you know what I
bet there are good people in Fresno but
amazing people they all laugh until they
drink yeah they laughed they had a good
time he was having a good time but just
too good of a time he didn't know how to
turn off the SP and sometimes that's
what happens with dumb people we get
dumb stories sent To Us by our awesome
fans uh Daniel you've got one let's
ready this presented by Jake grony at
Jake gr J grony great dude I love this
headline man protesting wedding ven
launches firework at newlyweds in
helicopter he's he's had enough of this
[__] are the Newly Weds in the
helicopter yes and he launched a
firework from the ground and he's not
protesting love he's not protesting
weddings protesting the venue did he get
charged with a terrorist attack I don't
know shooting us that's a surface to air
newly red attack he lined up attempted
murder for sure so I I love that like
this is been boiling up for him he's
like I hate that whatever a farm next to
his house or is now strawberry Farm's
wedding venue it seems like unwise to
show launch one at a helicopter when now
the venue is empty and if you're
protesting it you're not going to hurt
anybody or if you really want to ruin
the like first of all you're not going
to hit the helicopter it's a wasted
gesture and you're going to get in
trouble sure if you really want to
protest the venue like stand outside
with a giant sign and say this place
sucks or there's Sal Manila here get
naked at someone's wedding you will ruin
the wedding just by being there cut the
cable really piss people off how mad is
he that he's just not been invited to
any of the weddings that's what it
is I live next door half that table's
empty you already paid for the plates
that's the last time you don't invite me
right I I've requested songs for my
house yeah one man's long-standing
history of making threats toward a
nearby wedding venue culminated with him
launching a firework at a helicopter
carrying a newly married couple Georgia
deputies say so Dan if
you.com like I
would.com I would identify you as a
fantastic Storyteller comedian who also
does great sketch sure we are identified
as twin comedians who have been doing it
for a long day you are this nees is a
fantastic that's how you're identified
if you you are identified as a man who
has had offered many threats to a long
standing history of that's how people
know you who's that guy over there that
be great if you start saying that to
like hosts on shows how do you want me
to bring up uh can you say I have a
longstanding
history I launched the
firework a newly W cou in helicopter did
you hit it no no you might have a but
he's going to hit it tonight guys please
welcome neesh you might have a crazy set
if you get brought up with that like
this dude's going to be a wild yeah he's
he's crushing it in prison right now
and then you're like an also
Conan she also mentioned both a Cherokee
County Deputy was working as a working
as security at an October 20 wedding
when he heard a mortar firework hurdling
towards a departing helicopter carrying
the newlyweds according to a Cherokee
County Sheriff's Office crime report God
so again was he heard the
like like he heard the he heard the
whistle well you can't stop that's
impressive impressive work right there
yeah around fireworks mainly bottle
rockets but
hey or just maybe they hear the like
like that the like yeah
that's so the couple is in the
helicopter yeah they're about to take
off in like a grand nothing can touch us
now I'm so happy this went off so well
we're about to start the rest of our
lives they must really love us I mean if
you're hearing I don't know if you're
hearing a helicopter every Friday and
Saturday at the end of a wedding so
you're proba somewhere around midnight
you're mad that has to be you're mad cuz
when I when people go oh we hate we we
shouldn't have so many concerts or the
night games at Wrigley are horrible and
I'm like you moved next to Wrigley
Field but I don't know that as weddings
you know and traditions and [__] that
people do it gets crazier I mean you
know uh reveal gender reveals and
[__] weddings getting crazier and
crazier I don't this person shouldn't
have done this but I don't think they
signed up to like live next to
or he lived there originally and now the
helicopters they came in then you came
and then the helicop definitely that has
changed his life but how bad or sad is
it that like he launches the firework up
they're taking off and she just turns
him was like babe you ordered
fireworks he like yeah we didn't almost
just die no cuz mortar firework is the
tube with the B I mean you're shooting
you're shooting it up in the air you can
get into some Pro level stuff that's Mor
fireworks after further investigation
the Sheriff's Office issued a warrant
for David Jeter captain on a charge of
making terrorist respect salute yeah
that kid I want to know where that kid
from the Jeter respect oh how old is
that kid now probably 20 25 I don't know
what you're were pring to that little
kid it's that it's that Jeter respect
commercial and he's a little kid in like
a denim shirt and he's he's got the
Yankees hat and it was like Jeter's last
game and he like tips his hat to him you
guys have never seen this yeah I know
I've seen it I wonder where that kid so
that's like how many years ago so Jeter
retired probably 2008 nine no no no
later that later than that 14 yes I
think like probably 10 years old so
that's and you're right that kid was
probably like 11 and he's probably 21
now he's Tommy
DeVito or he's Tommy DeVito's agent well
working oh yeah I did want to say this
after further investigation David Jeter
uh they charged him with making
terrorist IC threats according to
deputies while working his quote ful
Justice yes while working his quote I
just love this extra duty job the
officer who was working security not off
duty not side job like extra Duty he's
not he's also not a cop in this function
he's just a security officer although
he's you're always a cop you're always a
cop but to him he's like it's extra put
down extra duty job what's the
difference between extra Duty and Duty
extra Duty I could put it my knee in his
back duty I can go on his neck extra
Duty extra Duty no no body
cam while working his extra duty job the
officer was aware that other issues had
occurred at Rocky's Lake estate where
the wedding was being held the sheriff's
office said yep deputies said the owner
William Morris Rocky had a particular
problem with Jeter his last name is a
first name that's so it's Rocky vers
Jeter which feels like Philly vers New
York rocks Jeter and it's run by the
Willam AG I I went to a Rangers game a
couple weeks ago and uh they had like a
whole Rocky thing on like the jumbo scre
and and I was like yes that Philadelphia
icon cheering on this New York team
playing the Flyers they were playing the
San Jose uh sharks shks it was a great
game 10 goals that game yeah but like
when you want to get them pumped up they
play like a rocket speech like that so
our they also did the Michigan they did
the Spartans from 300 I'm like this only
fits at Michigan State Games right right
right we our thing is that Rocky bbo is
like from Philadelphia but he had like a
New
York like give him a Philly ACC hey yo
Adrian get out of that coma hey get into
the W while I'm fing wus and grab me a
quit quit hitting that meat hey grab me
a towel get a towel I need a towel don't
throw in towel I need a tow that would
no one would have watched that nobody
would watch
it uh okay so G it's Jeter versus Rocky
right Rocky had a particular problem
with Jeter who was accused of making
threats against his employees and
wedding guests before yeah can't
threaten a wedding guest David Jeter
lives in a rock it's in the hundreds
lives how many feet away from Rocky's
Lake estate in Woodstock okay it's in
the Woodstock New York right all right
Woodstock Georgia oh Woodstock Georgia
you guys want to guess it's I'll guess
I'll guess uh he's 300 50 ft away okay
he's 150 ft away you miss I would say I
would say 200t or
so just guessing off the distance of of
mortar uh mortar range but I feel like
David Jeter uses words like infiltrate
so he probably infiltrated the grounds
he's got camo on
and he's Bruce D in the burs come on uh
Jeter David Jeter lives 470 ft away
There He Go yeah just what's that like
uh one and 2/3 football field that's
within your shot of a helicopter for
sure coming in and going out big time
it's he's having Vietnam flashbacks
every Friday and Saturday I got him I
got this he lives 470 ft away from
Rocky's uh Lake estate in Woodstock
according to the report and has
repeatedly harassed passers by to access
parts of the venue deputies said guests
would need to take a golf cart that
would drive past Jeter's house where he
would make this is perect you don't like
them they so they have to to get from
where the parking is and then to the
venue they have to go past his house on
he would quote make sideways motions to
his neck with his hands no and yell
don't do it to the
guests it ain't going to last don't do
it take it from me's out here just this
it's been a long time since you see one
of these in the wild I don't know let's
cck Eastwood and and what's that movie
just saw Gran Torino I'm riding the L
train if I'm on the L and somebody's
just like I'm getting I'm off is it
worse if it's the thumb the thumb does
more violent but so they've banned this
from Sports you can't make this do I
know no but you know what they haven't
banned the smelling your fingers across
your nose which is what players now do
instead of they do for a first down
they'll go was it is it metf who plays
for Seahawks DJ is he the one who
learned Silo so he can say [__] that
they were Banning him from yeah DK did
that and then uh what's it called um the
guy the guy on the the ners that they
both got expelled at the same time did
the did did the reversing like number 14
uh [__] around and found out so good I
can't remember who it was but is it
Davis the receiver Davis Shane Gillis
got him to do G Davis yeah yeah he got
uh no it wasn't the baby what what did
he put him to sleep this thing yes
that's what it was it was that kid it
was the kid the meme and then he also he
also had um do the um the hypnotized
dance that that UK kid was doing yeah it
was amazing amazing and hilarious I love
it you could do that for charity if
you're a player be like I'll auction off
a celebration dance and then have it go
to a ra money for like breast cancer
awareness cuz remember when Brandon
Marshall was wearing mentalness Brandon
Marshall was wearing mental health
mental uh health shoes and they find him
repeatedly and now it's a event in the
in yes that they find him like six weeks
in a row by the way you're absolutely
right that this should be auctioned off
for Charities and stuff I saw the Miami
Dolphins do the roller coaster one where
he literally they get they all sit down
and he moves his like they put the bar
down on all of them that's awesome it's
phenomenal amazing amazing um okay so
David's out in his yard tell people
don't do it don't do it don't do it it's
not going to last this guy uh he yells
at people before where was okay terrible
a disorderly conduct report was filed
against Jeter as a suspect in 2022
according to the report on the night of
the firework incident the bride and
groom uh were celebrating the end of
their wedding at Rocky's real uh Rocky
Lake estate they boarded the helicopter
at about 9:45 p.m. that's early to leave
that's early to leave your own wedding
it's late to hear a chopper very but
early to leave your wedding if you are
not near you're not in a major city or
you're not near like a hospital and
you're in a chapter even if you are near
a hospital you're a rural like where I'm
Bor in rochell Illinois you're here in a
helicopter at 9:45 they are airlifting
somebody
window shaking it's Jurassic 450 ft away
the helicopter starts going in his
Jurassic Park your drink is shaking his
patio furniture is just everywhere right
but that's normally it is too I feel
like blows it back into place you're
denting my car
projects his dog stopped barking a long
time ago yeah he s and alone he still
calls out though around that time the
officer was told by an employee that
Jeter was out side of his home quote
yelling in Anger that's his uh bio the
deputy said the helicopter lifted off
about 15 minutes later and while flying
off many people in the venue heard a
firework shoot off and explode it came
in quote close proximity to the
helicopter as it was still low the
officer he didn't let it even get up it
was still low the officer said and the
owner suspected Jeter may have launched
the rocket no [__] who else launched it
yeah it wasn't the mother of the bride
one guy who had a surprise GI
I slept with her Jeter had mentioned in
a previous encounter that he was quote
protesting the wedding venue the
sheriff's office said the officer said
he was only aware of one firework being
launched to check if Jeter had
discharged the explosive Morris
contacted his daughter to check her
outdoor camera footage according to the
sheriff so Rocky has a daughter who's
got outdoor camera footage literally
trained on this guy's house oh he stairs
at the camera Morris's daughter lives
across the street from Jeter they've got
a whole half field McCoy situation here
and had previously put up a camera
around her home due to a history of
being harassed by Jeter after going over
the video footage the owner set a clip
to the officer that that he said showed
the firework launching from Jeter's home
yep I mean I'd say about 500 feet you're
shooting firework that's pretty good aim
it's amazing also might have just been a
Roman Candle which is probably is
technically just a mini I know
difference but yeah if it's a Roman cand
weed to have Roman Candle Wars you just
hold light the bottom and you hold it
and it shoots up these little balls oh
okay and we' run and shoot them at each
other very stupid and very fun very
stupid very wiconsin so fun and Illinois
all over the all over the the by state
area right uh after going over the
footage they see that he had a firework
launching from J's home quote had this
firework hit the helicopter it could
have cause problems or damage to the
helicopter yes no kidding you're lucky
it didn't bro the helicopter pilot in
mon Georgia is may not necessarily be
trained for a firework hitting there for
a fir but I still hope like a wedding
full of drunk people saw the firewor
like ooh like they just roll with it
thought he he did it David's action
scared a lot of people as multiple
people observing thought something bad
had happened to the helicopter oh yeah
as a result of the incident the officer
said that he had probable cause to
charge Jeter with terroristic acts yep a
warrant was issued because his actions
were escalating the officer wrote Jeter
was booked into jail this is like two
months ago October 24th by the sheriff's
office he charges were listed at his
disorderly conduct terroristic threats
poed
woodwest of Atlanta just for fun what do
you think his bond was what do you think
the Bond was firing a firework David
Jeter yep who they don't give his age
but are we all sort of in like a
618 old that's too close to you for me
to you guys I know you're young 65 65 I
just want it's got a little bit of me
it's late 50s early 60s that's what I
see I think you're right I think his
bond was 250 ,000 250,000 bucks 80k 80k
yeah I'm going to it's Mak in Georgia so
I going say probably close to like
$50,000
3,500 that's it almost worth it and they
knew this [__] wasn't going to
come up with it it's too much but it's
almost worth I'll do it again I'll do it
again I don't understand how it's not
attempted murder though I know agreed
you shot a fiery ball out a [__]
helicop that's moving moving that has
people on it that's murder that's attemp
you're up next I'll obviously tell my
stuff when we come back we'll and we'll
talk about nees what he's got going on
all right it's D people Town nees Patel
is with us we'll be right
back hey guys welcome back to the show
Daniel great job in the first story and
we're going to find out what uh nees is
doing his tour and everything and he's
got a great little story that he's doing
in in his act right now that is very Dum
dumb people Town oriented but before we
do that Daniel let people know where
people can see you yeah the movie's out
right now wine club my my uh my feature
you can uh see me be a newlywed who gets
stuck in a wine cult uh it's very fun
that's uh that's go to Apple uh for that
you can also go to wine club if you're
this is before January 17th that we're
doing a Premiere here in LA and you can
see how uh you can get a chance to come
to that that Premiere that screening
everything else just catch me the rose
gold tour is still going the special
will probably drop in April but to come
out and see that hour before I'm done
with it go to danielv van.com I'm doing
DC I'm doing uh Midwestern dates with
Wisconsin de Mo uh doing comedy Fort
this year in 201 as well I know I love
them as well so everything is up at
Daniel van kirk.com pacificnorthwest
it's all there you'll find it I love it
uh and neash tell us about your tour
where you're going to be where people
can catch you how they can do it for
sure I'm on tour right now it's called
the fast and loose tour you get tickets
at fast and lo tour.com uh if this is
out I'm not sure when uh I'll be in San
franisco go this weekend December 16th
closing the year out at Madison Square
Garden December 30th holy crap the
theater not the big
one dud it's awesome and then all of
next year I'll be everywhere from Salt
Lake City to Cleveland to Vegas again to
uh Dallas Austin San Antonio everywhere
you can find me fast and Loos tour.com
and you're doing like mostly thousand
2,000 C theaters yeah a bunch of
theaters and then a lot of clubs to get
in the Reps before I think I'm hoping to
shoot my special in May in Dallas at the
Majestics so we'll get some Club reps in
before then Miami everywhere yes awesome
dude I love it come see him and you were
saying that like obviously we love that
you on this it was a dumb news story
that came out here of that pilot who
went nuts oh yeah that I'm talking about
it in my set so want to give it away but
like give us a little of how you it's a
story about that pilot that did shrooms
for two days and then tried to bring a
plane down right oh my he's charged with
like 170 counts 83 counts of attempted
murder oh my god oh for 83 This dude
went wait but when you do that many
when you do that many mushrooms it's
like you're trying to land the plane
that is you yes I mean that that was his
whole angle right that's that's what I
was doing I thought I was still tripping
no man you want a
plane no man seat Bel sign was on yes
yeah so like there are people out there
who have done shrooms and thought that
they were piloting you actually were
doing he was actually he's actually a
pilot he's in the jump seat of the plane
like with his two boys and uh 35,000 ft
he's like I'm not okay tries to bring
plane down wild like hey man in the old
days that guy would have just been drunk
now in this day and age we're like
mushrooms this guy doing shrooms shrooms
legal legal in Denver uh I love it catch
him on tour phenomenal stand up and you
guys will absolutely love it I'm going
to jump into the story okay this is sent
in by keyless Chuck at again intro again
intro like new new new a person to send
it in uh this is the this is the
headline it's great Pennsylvania man
steals cakes with his face on them
police say wait so he'll like order a
cake have them put his face on it and
then a cake with his face on it I'm
going to show you it right now that's
the cake that's not what I would have
thought you didn't think he were going
to look like that that looks like just
photoshopped right but that is a cake
like looks like funeral cake by the way
but how good does that cake look to he
looks like Colin Kaepernick's cousin
right that's a fun who like laid down
during the night David Kaepernick all
right well this guy's name is dequay
Anthony Jackson okay sorry Mr Jackson
why the deai Anthony Jackson's a fine
name Anthony Jackson's a great name why
ask why deai deai why don't ask deai ask
dequ not is accused of stealing cakes
from Weiss markets located at 1204
Millersville Pike shout out to shout out
to markets
right go get your cake on it that cake
if that picture isn't photoshopped if
that's how good they can put a photo on
okay do you know they can put photos on
cake Crystal Clear that's amazing that
you got like a laser printer on that
cake technology is incredible it's
incredible has a face for cakes he he's
got a cake face right all right so I'm
not going to tell you how old he is but
uh you saw fun to guess off of that cuz
that's that's a range we'll guess that
later we'll do it later okay had
supposedly ordered cakes on online and
had his face printed on them so he
ordered them Dan called it face I'm in
this dumb logic but never paid for them
prior online to com to the store to pick
them up I wonder if that's something
that people do so they're just like so
when you are dealing with the employees
at a Weiss's you figure they're just
just trying to get through the day right
they're not going to know who ordered
online versus who always I always think
about this when I pick up food like if
you order sushi down by by my house and
I walk in and I'm like Randy and they
give it to me yeah I'm like do you know
if we paid it or not like you do but
like I'm always like do you know if
you're Randy yeah do you know if you're
Randy they don't care they don't check
they Chipotle had Chipotle has two of
the craziest honor systems in our
economy right now the first one is that
you you're not going to take the whole
bottle of the Chipotle I mean sorry
Chipotle it's been taken I'm on record
it's like Liam n's kids Tak right and
then the one that they other did is they
just set up a rack with letters and you
would just walk in and grab your
Chipotle and walk out and they would
just have it like a to L you know
whatever why can't someone just take the
one that well the one people don't want
they want the one on Hollywood advine it
lasted for about two weeks I'm not even
going through that much but I know I
went in once and then I went in a couple
weeks later and they were like all
orders are behind the counter of course
of course spreads like wildfire just
walk in you know you can just walk in
into chiping the Commodities Exchange
with the sandbag and the thing people
just come like this one feels like it
has more food than I'm going to take
this how much food do you want just gaug
so us you just see a guy weighing two
bags he's like also you know someone's
stealing it when they come in and be
like I'm just going to grab mine from d
and like no one ever say that my theory
was I know he stoen but if you order a
cake with your face on it and then you
don't pick it up let's say you let's say
you say you need it on Thursday and but
you really don't need it till Friday
don't waste the cake exactly on Friday
isn't that cake going to be sold for
like a third off because they know
nobody's going to buy it who wants a
dick way but you need the cake Friday
you say you need it Thursday that way
Friday I would
buy for like your birthday your birthday
I would get you that cake I want the
cake you want the we have a disease okay
we have a weird comedy and this is going
to be funny disease the average person
is like I'm not buying that this is
almost a genius hack I would think
unless you just love cakes and you're
like I don't give a [__] with spes on
this cake just grocery store and
get grocery store sheet cakes I've said
this before they are the best cuz they
still put the chemicals in that kill you
and it tastes good that all right so a
witness confirmed that a person who the
person who ordered the cake was the same
person pictured in the photos that were
printed on the cake the police explained
this witness also said the payment was
not made online for the bakery items
who's the witness it's definitely
someone who works at the cake thing it's
not just someone else buying I saw man
steal he didn't look like he face yeah
he stole his face on the cake Jackson
came to the store picked up the cakes
and then he walked to the store and
selected four canned products no this is
his non shalant you could you draw a
picture of the suspect it's right there
it's right here we have it on the cake
two candles a small package of cupcakes
and a box of chips box of chips cupcakes
that's a little hat on a hat isn't it he
proed to the self checkout scans the
small box of cupcakes and the box of
chips a payment of how much was made the
police St in the release box of chips
and a box of cupcakes box of chips and
then he didn't scan the C and he didn't
scan the cake so you know that's like
there's so much theft going on with with
with self checkout people have been like
printing their own you take the thing
off the banana and you put it on the TV
box and you scan them it's like all
these games are so new to me man God
damn I'm missing out I know so how much
money do you think he he probably paid
like $88.50 I'm going to go 1122 what do
you think 1123 buck ah there you go he
paid get transfers in Towes
$12.99 that's the way you well played
well played the cakes were valued at how
much the cake the face cakes face cakes
were valued at how much oh that's at
least that's at least a $22 cake so you
so there were two so how many so you're
saying $44 okay what do you think yeah I
would say each cake is like 30 something
bucks so probably like 60 bucks to what
do you think those cakes are $50 each
that's $100 worth of cakes get your in
townies because those cakes were
$904 nice job J 45 bucks a cake they
were never scanned or paid for according
to the story of the authorities Jackson
was identified through the photos
submitted again who did this yeah cuz he
sent the photo they also have his photo
digitally he sent right so he submitted
the photos in the K and the security
footage like like this is the easiest
detective had one cake that was just his
home
address here's where I hang out all the
time uh cakes being to security footage
Court of the police he is a criminal
record and complet a probation for his
uh 2021 sentencing for retail theft in
Burks County in so he's already a retail
he's in jail and they're like what are
you in for murder as listen to this this
is really interesting as part of his
plea deal he agreed that he is banned
from all Target stores in Burks County
can't go to Target anymore more Target
save a lot of money okay in Lancaster he
committed offenses in 2018 and 2021
serving probation 2 uh but he also gave
false identification to the police in
2018 show him the cake man so in that
case he uh participated I just love that
this is such a Brazen crime that like
you're going to put your own face on the
thing that they can identify you with
this is a cry for
help less of a crime more a cry Ard is a
program that allows qualified offenders
to put uh their possession or
prosecution on hold as they complete the
program once completed they can seek
engagement of their record for related
charges we're going to get out of here
on this story and then we're going to
then I'm going to send it to Jay who's
going to give us a little taste of what
he's got uh how old is deai Anthony
Jackson who did that you saw the picture
I'll show it to you again Fallen
Kaepernick some Fallen Kaepernick the
question is about him is how this could
he could look great yeah I think he's a
dumb kid H so how old do you think he is
say he's 20 years old 20 years old Jay
what do you think 26 26 you miss yeah I
was say early 20s but let's call it 22
cuz I say 20 because he he why is he not
just stealing alcohol I'll line up with
okay there you go all right get your
answers in townies because deai Anthony
Jackson Who Stole two cakes with his
face on you say
37 6 no he is he ready 24 years old you
guys were all around it you guys were
right around it you're the closest one
you had it this is the early this is the
early beginnings of a mastermind
criminal he's just getting his footing
right now he should be the new host of
Cake Boss am I right how great would
that be what a loophole though I mean
Weiss needs to step it up if you just
just order cakes without paying for them
so Weiss is going to they're going to do
what Chipotle did they're like there's
no longer the racks we trusted you we
started with trust and now we can no
longer trust no longer take your cake
through the self checkout there you go
Jay give us a little taste of what we
got uh when you want meat really badly
okay that's good good to know Dan knows
he's won two meat Raffles two seven
seven God damn it it's a Wisconsin thing
every summer in Wisconsin I just enter
meat wrap bar they just be like oh we're
doing a meat raffle and I go okay don't
sign me up five bucks down for a ticket
and then you a dollar dude a dollar a
ticket they get two wooden paddles with
numbers on it and then on the ceiling
fan a guy in the back opens up his vanan
and he's just got meat yeah what the do
a whole yeah I do it in my I do it in my
current hour this is incredible hash
white people all right uh we're going to
take a break we come back uh one last
story and we'll tell you what we've got
going on St people Town neh Patel is
with us we'll be right
back sck around make a sound there's
more hey guys I want to talk about this
notion of spending money that you don't
realize you're spending on subscriptions
that you forgot that you're still a part
of I signed up for this golf tip service
and I was helping my golf swing for a
while and then I forgot about it I
realized I'm still paying for it and
I've been actually tried to contact them
so many times it's taken so much time to
figure it out and I just
need a way to slim things down get rid
of the subscriptions I don't need and
that is where rocket money comes in I
love these guys me too rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills so I can see all my
subscriptions in one place and if I see
something that I don't want or like Jay
said we don't use anymore I can cancel
it with AAP I never have to get on the
phone with customer service this is
amazing damn they'll even try to get you
a refund for the last couple months of
wasted money and negotiate to lower your
bills for you by up to 20% all you have
to do is take a picture of your bill and
Rocket money takes care of the rest that
literally cannot be more simple rocket
money has over 5 million users and is
helped save its members and average of
$720 a year with over 500 million in
cancelled subscriptions so stop wasting
money on things you don't use cancel
your unwanted subscriptions by going to
Rocket
money.com DPT that's rocket
money.com DPT
rocket.com
[Music]
D hey guys welcome back to the show
before we get into our last story Jay we
can let people know what we have going
on with us yeah we're going to be in
Portland at the great helium on January
3rd uh January 4th one night one night
January 4th January 5th uh wet City uh
Comedy Festival in we're at the
crocodile in Seattle so much fun and
then we're going to be in uh Fairbanks
Alaska I love Alaska so much have you
ever love Alaska the Anchorage once and
it was awesome Anchorage is great
Fairbanks even cooler I mean they're
they're both cool but Fairbanks is up
near the top of the Earth but great
comedy crowd we'll be on the 18th and
we're headlining that Comedy Festival on
the going be great and you get all the
tickets and again just you know Denver
super.com will be in Denver Comedy Works
and Mark Rel Comedy Castle in Detroit
and Acme Comedy Company and then the
moar Comedy Festival are you going to
moar this year I am not unfortunately
you'll be an Austin another anyway good
stuff super.com and we'll let you know
when other shit's coming on all right
Jay go for it all right this is sending
by Ryan Novak at the Ed JK tour um and
it's from Ozark's first so it's from our
home state we could play The Home State
game no worries all right Springfield
man we were just in Springfield we were
just in Springfield two billionaires in
Springfield Missouri uhhuh it's like too
many billionaires need too much money to
have in bilon in Missouri yeah seems
like a lot you probably need like a
million dollars and you could probably
like you know you could own people and
own the things they have tell them to
fix it up a little yeah uh springfi man
charged with demanding meat at gunpoint
so just enter the raffle Dan or just
order just order yeah hry guy yeah on
April 18 I need meat Republic Police
Department officers were called to a
Price Cutter so you know it's not even
good meat uh uh to respond to a call
about a robbery in which a man held an
employee at guno so that he would be
served meat so now if you're that
employee you go find the worst cut give
him the meat give it to him just give
him the meat give me not that one that's
that's not lean enough that's not lean
enough yeah that's problem you're you're
way too broad what kind what you want
here what do you want you want a Porter
House you want what do you Larry Jean
like and you know this guy's like a meat
connoisseur so he's like it's not
marbled enough it's not marbled enough I
want Wu Larry Jean gay Larry Jean gay
phenomenal he's the president of Harvard
just Kidd he was Destin he was uh I'm
not going to tell you his age we'll
guess at the end of Springfield is
charged with one felony count of
unlawful use of a weapon felony count of
armed criminal action court documents
show that officers respond to the scene
and ordered gay to get out of his truck
so they could arrest him so he already
did it yeah he he succeeded who did it
that guy in his truck over there who's
just parked at the grocery I like him
just sitting in his truck contemplating
what he just did come and get me who
who's the man he's like come and get me
[__] I got the Ground Round in an
interview gay said he went he's being
interviewed he said he went to Price
Cutter to buy Stakes he told the quote
good man who was helping him that they
needed to weigh the stakes however the
meat department was closed gay said at
that point he showed his gun just to say
I'm not stealing I need you here to help
me get a couple of these Stakes I'm not
going to hurt you so he just won't
accept show the gun show the gun he just
won't accept business hour
[__] off when [__] is open I don't
know I'm rooting for this guy right now
the officer ask how dare you close the
meat department the officer this is why
I love this officer did it right like he
makes he's like I'm going to make you
tell me why you were wrong right you
know when a cop does that to you tell me
what you think you did wrong right the
officer asked gay why he thought the
people in the store called the police
uhhuh why do you think these guys called
the police on you bud and told them he
was threatening them with a gun gay said
I don't know I have no idea
Rook tonight four he was like I don't
know I have no idea you tell me it's not
my first time stealing meat officer
right I'm not falling to this I've done
this before I've been but then the cop's
like well you just said you stole meat
godamn damn it the employee said he
received a call from the meat department
like if you work in the meat department
great bar in San Francisco the meat
department great great gay bar in any
City me Department dep for the meat
department about a man packing his own
meat all right come on so he went behind
the he's like I'm doing this myself I'm
going to do this myself I'm going to
pack meat and he was packing me the
employee reached gay uh approached gay
and told him that he could not be there
gay got upset and said that he was going
to keep doing what he was doing the
employee he's too vag for me way too vag
this is such a beautiful dramatic
reenactment happening like like 911
emergency like that show this
reenactment would be going keep rip the
the paper off the I'm just a gay packing
meat let me do it what do you want
what's your problem I want meat okay
well we're not giving you well I might
do something about that what exactly I
don't know what's happening now I'm
going to do what I'm doing he's way too
vague for me but also maybe that's his
way being like I technically never did
anything never said I was going to I
just implied I had a gun I had a gun uh
the employee said he was not going to
help him with the meat which doesn't
which does not mean don't do it I'm not
going to going to help you with hey man
you want to go back there and do it once
he held the gun to my throat pushed it
into my throat
okay that take a
turn maybe that had something to do I
decided to comply this is all sudden act
three of pul fiction we like oh wow
we're going this way at the time of this
writing gay was being held at the Green
County jail on how much Bond what's the
bond on this guy I mean you put a gun to
a person's throat push it in Missouri
though yeah that's true and I feel like
like I was really good as a test taker
when I was a kid and I feel like you
wouldn't cue this up if we hadn't had
the $3,500 making Georgia thing already
so I want I'm going to guess I'm going
to guess $110,000 $10,000 from 20 that's
what I was going to say I'll
go $5,000 $5,000 from Daniel get your
answers in shot at your ham radio and
then we'll guess his age okay $50,000
wow that's okay okay they don't think
lar gay should be on the streets man he
shouldn't
no
for [__] ribey yeah turning Price
Cutter into price we're being nice too
we keep saying Stakes he probably just
wanted [__] bone and pork chops
listen bone and pork chops or whatever
ve Salsberry steaks all right we're
going to get out of here on this how old
is Larry Jean gay show the gun push in
the throat owns a truck I'll let you go
first pack his own meat how or last you
can choose D would you rather go last
I'm say I'm going to go first I'm going
to say 57 years old this is man has been
through some [__] exactly what I thought
he's a simple man he just wants to eat
his meat in his truck he's he's not
going to go that far to get it but he's
going to put it he's going to do
something also Larry is a an old man's
name so I you don't mean a lot of like
what's your son's name Larry I'd say 64
I think you guys are both way too young
I'm going to say this dude's 71 years
old 71 years old one of you is one year
off okay so I'm going to go
65 go up or down that said 57 you 57
I'll say 58 I would that's that's where
I would have gone to I'll go I'll go uh
71 72 72 years old get your answers in
nees thank you for joining us on this
show we love it go see him on tour go
see Daniel on tour come see us support
Live Comedy it's what you do Larry Jean
gay mhm is 70 years old
he was so worn out that's why he had to
sit in his truck he was like all right
give me a
minute I got to breathe before I mean
just to get you
know like that I haven't felt that alive
in years and then he had like super old
guy to be like I'm not saying what I'm
going to do he's not jittery and young
he's old dealing with COPD come on now
there you that's a show you guys that's
how we do it dumb people town we love
you I don't know when this is going to
drop but if it's around the new year
happy New Year and all that stuff and oh
[__] we got to get back to
[Music]
work